des douigners des policiers des maires
qui sont ces ripous sur lesquels
s'appuie le crime organisé et comment
les criminels font-ils pour les
corrompre il y a eu par exemple ce
doignier de l'aéroport roisser Charles
de Gaulle soupçonné d'avoir aidé pendant
2 ans des trafiquants à importer de la
cocaïne d'Amérique du Sud il a été
interpellé le 8 mars dernier 10 mois
plus tôt un employé du même aéroport qui
avait accès au secteur de sûreté était
intercepté en flagrant délit alors qu'il
venait de récupérer dans les toilettes
un sac à d's qui contenait 16 kg de
cocaïne déposé par une mulle entre 2016
et 2021 le nombre des dossiers de
corruption abondit de 46 pour car
pendant longtemps ces affaires ont
prospéré dans l'ombre la corruption
étant très difficile à prouver selon le
commissaire Guillaume ezar pour faire
fructifier leur business les groupes
criminels ont besoin d'information que
seuls les services étatiques possèdent
mais les salariés du privé sont aussi
très ciblés par exemple avec la
technique du cheval de 3 qui est très
populaire dans les ports français à
Marseille au Havre et en Martinique des
extracteurs se cachent dans un conteneur
déposé sur le quai par un complice près
d'un autre conteneur pour y récupérer la
drogue cette technique implique
forcément des complices le docker
chauffeur le chauffeur du camion ou
encore du personnel portuaire ces
organisations criminelle ultraviolent
sont prêtes à tout pour garder leur
accès au port pas moins de 26 kidnapping
et tentatives lié à la cocaïne dans le
port du Havre ont été répertorié entre
juin 2016 et décembre 2021 les gangs
criminels peuvent aussi acheter des
surveillants de prison pour laisser
passer en cellules de la drogue ou des
téléphones ils peuvent soudoyer des
agents de préfecture pour obtenir de
faux papiers mais la France n'est pas
non plus corrompue de manière
systématique elle ne figure qu'à la 21e
place mondiale entre l'Uruguay et les
Séchelles selon l'association
Transparency
International